[Musique]
à
dans la nuit avant laquelle un procès
appuyer cette maison monsieur
on a mené les hausses en vendée
souveraines et des moyens pour la 1935
en effet je me souviens mais je crois
que nous ne sont plus les mêmes normes
clés du tout j'aime bien réquisition des
légers jose la semaine
qu'à cela ne tienne je vous le donne et
c'est mon père une tare en stats
mouettes avec des chansons docteur sting
que vous allez vous pourrez mais
enregistre brésil et gilberto gil avec
une musique locale et réquisitionnent
[Musique]
il
je veux
un goûteur matin
[Musique]
les
ah je suis persuadé qu'il y a des sous
dans cette édition
[Musique]
le chanteur ont réalisé des prouesses
qui surclasse celle de leur magnifique
est née de la guerre de 1914
certes l escadrille ont à leur actif qui
aurait paru il ya seulement un mois
[Musique]
eh ben on attend chansons elles sont les
chouchous dans la semaine lolo l'ubs à
vous maintenant d ici outre l'accord
discuté
attendez je vous donne le chouchou de la
semaine
robert plant l'ex chanteur de led
zeppelin et dolly parton de la country
music
avec ces nouveaux sauts sa nouvelle
voire assez régulière
[Musique]
je crois que nous avons perdu la bière
messier toujours j'espère simplement que
l'on de notre ancienne amitié vous
accepterez des me donner les jo de la
semaine
il a même envers les tonnages pour le
donneur classe
c'est une galerie à disque féminin voilà
rappelez vous son visage sur le corps de
la manche dans ses meilleurs et en
deuxième je vous montre et lisa wood
celle de la musique planante je crois
que vous en aurez besoin pour rêver
appui à toi mais je suis chaud à bientôt
monsieur l'officiel mais mon père
calvin le seigneur pour performer
le tambourin
à comment avons nous pu faire la guerre
à des gens comme ça
[Musique]
dans les cieux
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu